it's a breakfast time and to actually
listen grab out the guy
[Music]
because some I think this is common
Sunnah I've sewed about mother not soda
planted about a month ago it's taking a
bit of a hammering from am not hammering
a slight smattering of s not damage it
uses like spinach
now a couple more days I think of these
yeah he's a snappy Nairobi and sown in
region I gotta I harvested them a bit
glam squad from here and have some beans
of thing
that's an African blue basil
now some more think some flower shoots
of Chinese chives garlic chives very
quite tasty the best in a sandwich but
I'm gonna do a stir-fry yeah we gonna do
a quick stir-fry be that this is one
being I've got some let's see what we
got underneath are looking at beautiful
nobody can see the thousands of buggers
wearing they're screaming away so
finally cracked the farming worms now
I've got thousands of them which is a
good thing
all right I'll probably probably kiss
you might say
I'm often visiting Jacques herb farm in
Gloucestershire and she has opened a
sort of five or six times a time here
quite a famous person I shall show you
around
try
tipping up over one of my man hold I'm
used to I use electron ships and we're
used to come in
I might have overdone it with them
buying stuff from Jackie this cost me a
fortune
I'm gonna have to be reposting all of
this it's all them because I need them
it's going to need to survive the winter
this is like a peppery leaf thing and
nice I think it's a the herb of
some sort or garden as I what I really I
really went there to get this which is
some for cliffs and firms or rocks alpha
and and instead I got that and if and
all of this so I'm totally mad anyway
there you go
I'm putting up some some plants for
keeping overwintered endorsed with
central heating all the rest of it and
one of the biggest problems is root rot
so you gonna make yeah yeah your soil in
your pots really really um free draining
so I've put half grit and a half equal
equal mass air not mass volume of grit
and compost
I'll put a little bit of organic
fertilizer in as well give us the
maximum chance of keeping keeping the
plants alive
remove the winter
[Music]
she's a pop round and brought together
now course what we gonna do my new
people I think I'll use a bigger pot
it's a bit deeper loosen a few of the
this is the burn jelly plant bobbing
frutescens it's suppose we could for
burns and stuff it's not edible is to be
applied
you know externally well I don't take my
take your own medical advice but this is
what I'm told it does so um so yeah the
is very very tender so it's an African
plant so it's going to be staying
indoors there's a very pretty flower
let's see if we can get a shot that when
I see ya there it's pretty in full
flower this is the last remaining a
couple of florets off it so then they in
full flower it's very pretty
we should see I won't even see that one
am it flowers next we're getting new
shoots coming out here so what I shall
do it's pretty cutting back there and
they we grow I'm being cruel to be kind
you're greater their plan then we put it
you turn the leaves are eaten and it's
yeah they're quite peppery it's related
to the Vietnamese coriander a plastic
area having a super scary as well have
different types of nuts pursue carrier
Hydra Piper Piper is pepper by rubriz is
the red version of the water pepper
classic area water
let's get started
do not want to think
[Music]
so yeah nights are closing in okay I've
got used to having lots of fans time and
evenings to get things done but it's
times racing on again
yeah that's the much of the reasons why
we gotta get things ready for indoors
and winter the winter garden say so yeah
so I'll finish up now and then do more
tomorrow and but ya know I'm pleased and
they're quite warm ornamental Oregon and
on their regardin it's quite pretty I
think it's related to a course can mint
of course can course can regard oh we've
got a caper bush over there which I want
a great big that's that's why I said bit
bit of a bigger bomb yeah African jelly
burn jelly I'm really great for the
flowers let's face it
and this one's good this is a classic
area because the other person Kerry I've
got the the Vietnamese coriander is so
good and I've tried a few leaves of this
I'm trying here but yes I hope for that
I tend to eat the Vietnamese coriander
you know two or three times a week so
hopefully it's a good addition it's a
perennial so I'm gonna try and keep it
alive and take cuttings that sort of
thing so should be good for you